CHARLES L. CHEN: Hi, everyone.
So we're here to talk about
advancing web accessibility
with ChromeVox.
I'm Charles Chen.
I have two of my colleagues
here with
me, Volker and David.
You guys want to say
hi to everyone?
VOLKER SORGE: Hello.
DAVID TSENG: Hi, everyone.
CHARLES L. CHEN: OK.
So let's get started.
Here's a brief overview
of what we'll be
talking about today.
Stat off with an introduction
about what is ChromeVox.
David will take you on a
walk through the DOM.
Volker will discuss
reading math.
I will talk about how to use
ChromeVox APIs in your own
applications and web apps.
And then we'll have a conclusion
to sum up what
we've talked about.
So with that, what
is ChromeVox?
Well, ChromeVox is a screen
reader for Chrome which brings
the speed, versatility, and
security of Chrome to
visually-impaired users.
What's special about ChromeVox
is that we built all of this
with web technologies, such
as HTML5 and JavaScript.
So there's no impedance
mismatch between what
ChromeVox does and the rest of
the web and your web apps.
This allows us to advance
accessibility at the same rate
as all of you innovate and
create new exciting web
applications and really push
the boundaries of what is
possible to do inside
the browser.
There are huge benefits for end
users and web developers.
For end users, you get a screen
reader that's built
into your system.
On any Chrome OS machine, you
just press Control-C, and it
will start talking.
So it's right there.
It's also available
on desktops.
And for web developers, you get
something really unique.
You have a screen reader that
works inside your browser that
fits with your development
workflow.
You can do some work, run
ChromeVox on it, and then
listen to it and see what
it sounds like.
Because it is built with web
technologies, there isn't any
sort of mismatch between what
you would expect, in terms of
you can do with JavaScript and
the underlying platform.
The underlying platform
is JavaScript and web.
So any time you want to do
something that's custom, there
is a way for you to do it.
And we've opened up several APIs
to help you create better
auditory experiences
on the web.
And with that, I will now hand
it over to David, who will
give us an overview of how
you walk through the DOM.
Probably just a little bit
to your right, OK?
OK.
Perfect.
DAVID TSENG: Thanks, Charles.
Good evening, everyone.
My name is David Tseng.
I'm a software engineer on
the Accessibility Team.
I work on ChromeVox
and Chrome OS.
So tonight I'm going to give
you a behind the scenes
insider look at how ChromeVox
works under the hood.
So as you can see above on the
slide, to the left you have a
pretty innocent looking
piece of markup.
It's pretty simple.
And unordered list of links and
an editable text, input
type equals text,
and a button.
So if you ask yourself, well,
how does a screen reading
actually take something like
this and generate a
description and make it possible
for a keyboard-only
user, or someone who doesn't
see the screen, to explore
this content?
How does someone do that?
I can take you through some
alternatives and how ChromeVox
actually does it.
So you can imagine, I could
just take all of the text
content inside of the
unordered list
and just speak it.
So the problem with that is we
don't get any of the semantics
such as this is a list and
these are some links.
So that's probably
not a good idea.
How about, say, let's let the
user move from the structure
of this markup, so we can
imagine a system where we let
the user land on the unordered
list, let them move down into
the links and move about in the
links and move out, then
go to, say, the editable
text field.
That's a little closer to
what ChromeVox does.
So what it actually
does ChromeVox do?
Well, we centered around and
we converged on the idea of
granularity.
Let me define what
a granularity is.
A granularity consists of two
things, some notion of what a
leaf node is, so how deep did we
go in this tree structure,
and what it means to go to
a next or previous item.
I'll go ahead and show you what
our base granularity is,
which we call Object.
Now for this, we actually define
a leaf node as any sort
of interesting element, such
as a link or a button or an
editable text field.
and the next or previous item
just as one of these
interesting items.
So with that, I'm going to go
ahead and enable ChromeVox and
show you what it's like to
navigate in this very
sequential fashion.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Enabling
spoken feedback.
Article list with four items.
Web, link list item.
DAVID TSENG: So this is the
first interesting item.
And you'll notice that ChromeVox
said article and the
text of the link and the role,
link, and played an earcon,
which is analogous to an
icon, just a sound
representing some concept.
So the article, which you heard,
is the context, which
means that this markup was
surrounded by something that
was an article, an audio role.
All right.
So if I continue navigating,
I'll end up on another link
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Maps,
link list item.
DAVID TSENG: And another link.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Images,
link list item.
Gmail, link list item.
Google.
DAVID TSENG: And that's
actually a paragraph.
So that's a basic introduction
to one of our first
granularities, object.
So what are some other
interesting granularities?
Well, we also have defined
a character granularity.
And using that definition
I just gave you,
what does it mean?
Well, it just means that the
leaf node is now a text node,
and the next and previous items
are just the next and
previous characters within
that text node.
So I have a command in ChromeVox
that says Change
Granularities.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: [INAUDIBLE]
character, G, O, O,
G, L, E. Echo.
DAVID TSENG: I was able to scan
that text node just by
walking through the
characters.
And you also heard a nice
feature of ChromeVox that does
a phonetic map for
the letters.
So if there's any ambiguity in
the text-to-speech, such as an
engine that doesn't have the
clearest announcement of
characters, we can give users
another hint after a little
bit of a pause and speak the
word that phonetically can
describe that character.
So we have some other
granularities, the usual ones
that you would expect,
word and line.
So those are interesting
because they break on
different delimiters.
And so the next and previous
definition of the granularity
is the only thing that we
need to change there.
Beyond these basic
granularities, ChromeVox
supports tables.
And we're able to get the
tables to fit into this
definition by saying, OK, next
and previous are rows, and
leaf nodes are just the
rows' items elements.
And finally, we have some
interesting developments that
just got released with ChromeVox
27, which was just
put up on the web store,
that knows how to
deal with math content.
And with that, I will invite
Volker Sorge to talk more on
that subject.
VOLKER SORGE: Thank you
very much, David.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Disabling
spoken feedback.
VOLKER SORGE: So my name
is Volker Sorge.
I'm actually a Senior Lecturer
at the University of
Birmingham in the UK.
But I'm spending a year working
with the ChromeVox
team here in California in
order to work on getting
mathematics spoken with
the ChromeVox engine.
And it is a sad fact that what
is still the biggest obstacle
for a fully inclusive
education for
visually-impaired students is
that much of the scientific
content that's available out
there is practically
inaccessible.
So at the ChromeVox team, we've
realized this, and we're
trying to make some way towards
making some of this
content accessible by at least
making the mathematics that
can be found on the web out
there accessible via a screen
reader
And as a consequence, we
implemented aural rendering
for mathematical content
in ChromeVox.
And if you're not familiar how
math really works on the web,
math is generally given in
MathML format, or it's being
rendered from either MathML or
other formats using MathJax.
And with ChromeVox, we can now
deal with both types of
mathematical content
that's on the web.
As a consequence, spoken math
is now supported on all
platforms that support Chrome.
So if you were within a Chrome
browser, you can use ChromeVox
in order to have math spoken.
And what might be particularly
interesting for developers, of
course, is that if you're, for
instance, developing the Epub3
reader, you can leverage all the
work we put into ChromeVox
using the WebViews interface.
And thereby, for instance, have
spoken math on Android
tablets or smartphones.
Right.
So let me dive into the details
a bit, how math is
actually being rendered.
Usually, it's rendered more
beautiful than this.
And I'll just tell you
why this is the case.
Here.
This is how math is
being rendered.
And you might recall
this equation.
This is the solution to the
quadratic equation.
Actually, it's two solutions.
And the way it's being given
generally on the web is by
using a MathML markup
language.
MathML, as you can see on the
left of this slide, is a
fairly straightforward XML
representation of what you
have up there as the
mathematical formula.
So you can fairly easily map
those, the x to the x and the
equals to the equals.
And then you have kind of a
structured tree representation
of what the math formula
is there.
Unfortunately, not every
browser renders MathML
straight away.
And as a consequence, there's
a tool out there, which is
called MathJax, which
can render math in
all browsers similarly.
And as a matter of fact, on this
slide actually we used
MathJax to render the slide.
And notice the little hiccup
we had in the beginning
because the rendering sometimes
breaks a bit and you
have to do a little reload.
So on the right-hand side of
the slide you see how,
actually the MathJax
looks like.
So if you have, for instance,
the MathML in your DOM
originally, then MathJax will
replace it in the live DOM in
your browser with the
right-hand side.
And then you see immediately
this is a lot less obvious
what the mapping between the
actual elements of the
mathematical formula is, as a
lot of it is obscured by some
of the markup that is necessary
for the rendering.
All right?
Nevertheless, within ChromeVox,
we can speak both
MathML and MathJax similarly.
So the aural rendering is then
done normally doing the text
navigation.
And I'll show you how
this then sounds.
Let me switch on the ChromeVox
engine again.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Enabling
spoken feedback.
VOLKER SORGE: And now we go to
the next math expression.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: x equals minus
b plus/minus square root
of b squared minus 4ac
divided by 2a.
Math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right.
And so this is how it's being
pronounced while it's in
regular text.
So you can hear we are playing
a bit here with certain
changes of the speech.
For instance, we're changing the
rate and the pitch when we
go into the nesting of, say,
the square root or of the
numerator of the division.
Also, we change the pitch
when we go into sub and
superscript.
As a consequence, you can hear
where the square root actually
ends and where then the
division starts again.
Nevertheless, in many cases this
might be too fast for you
when you actually listen to this
expression, particularly
if it's a very large
expression.
What you then would like to
do and what we provide--
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Disabling
spoken feedback.
VOLKER SORGE: Let me switch
off feedback first.
What you then would like to do
is actually start exploring
the mathematical expression
a bit further.
And indeed, in ChromeVox we now
provide some functionality
in order to do this.
So what you could hear
originally when you listened
to the formula is that it's
being announced as a math
expression.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Enabling
spoken feedback.
x equals minus b plus/minus
square root of b squared minus
4ac divided by 2a.
Math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right.
Now it announced math.
Now we know we have a math
expression under our cursor,
effectively.
And now we can actually explore
it, if we want to.
So let's start exploring it.
That's ChromeVox backslash.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Entered math.
[EARCON SOUND]
x equals minus b plus/minus--
VOLKER SORGE: I'll stop
that speaking here.
But you could hear a little
earcon that tells you now
we've ended the math
expression.
Now we can start exploring it.
And you can now start exploring
it just regularly
with your cursor keys.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: x equals-- x.
VOLKER SORGE: All right?
So we can start the first
thing and then--
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Sticky--
Customizing Math.
VOLKER SORGE: Oops.
Now I've made a mistake here.
Sorry about that.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Disabling
spoken feedback.
VOLKER SORGE: Let's go back.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Enabling
spoken feedback.
[EARCON SOUND]
Wrap to top. x equals.
VOLKER SORGE: Let's enter
the expression again.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Entered math.
[EARCON SOUND]
x equals minus--
x equals minus b plus/minus
square root
of b squared minus--
VOLKER SORGE: OK.
I'll try this one time.
I hope this time it's
going to work.
We enter the expression.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: x equals minus
b plus/minus square root
of b squared minus 4ac
divided by 2a.
[EARCON SOUND]
Wrap to top. x equals
minus b plus/minus--
[EARCON SOUND]
Entered math.
VOLKER SORGE: Now we're in
the math expression.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: --minus b
plus/minus square root of--
VOLKER SORGE: Let's
try this again.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: --b square.
VOLKER SORGE: Nope.
I'm sorry.
This is the effect.
Sorry.
That's the demonstration
effect.
If you come to our Sandbox,
I'll demonstrate
this to you in detail.
I'm not quite sure why this
currently doesn't work.
So the idea is, if I had been
able to show that to you now,
that you can actually enter the
math expression and then
start walking the
math expression.
Currently, this traversal
follows fairly
the syntactic structure.
So you can listen to it, x
equals and then the expression
on the right-hand side
of the equality.
In the future, what we're
currently working on and what
will be released soon is that we
have a more systematic way
of actually exploring the
mathematical expression in a
particular way to customize
this exploration.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: x equals
minus b plus/minus.
x equals minus b plus--
x equals minus b-- x equals--
x equals--
x--
VOLKER SORGE: Ah.
There you go.
Sorry.
Now we're actually on
the expression.
Now it actually works.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Equals.
VOLKER SORGE: So now we're
actually exploring the
expression.
If you can look, we're exploring
the left-hand side.
If I go back--
CHROMEVOX VOICE: x--
VOLKER SORGE: --x--
CHROMEVOX VOICE: --equals--
VOLKER SORGE: --equals--
CHROMEVOX VOICE: --minus b--
VOLKER SORGE: Now we get the
right-hand side of the
expression.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: --b squared
minus 4ac divided by 2a.
VOLKER SORGE: And now we can
start exploring further.
So we get a bit further.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Minus b
plus/minus square root of b
squared minus 4ac.
VOLKER SORGE: So if you still
haven't fully understood
what's in the expression,
you can go further.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Minus b
plus/minus square root of b
squared minus 4ac.
VOLKER SORGE: And now
you can start
entering the square root.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: b squared
minus 4ac.
VOLKER SORGE: And so
on, and so forth.
So this is the basic idea
of how to explore the
mathematical expression.
And as you can see, we followed
pretty much the
syntactic structure as it is.
My apologies that I fat fingered
this and it didn't
work from the beginning.
Obviously, now we're
in the expression.
Now we can also leave the
expression again.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Cut.
VOLKER SORGE: And then once
we're outside the expression--
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Disabling
spoken feedback.
VOLKER SORGE: --we can then
actually continue working with
ChromeVox as normal.
Right.
Now one of the major things
about mathematics and speaking
mathematics is, of course, that
it can be very different,
four depending on the
mathematical domain you're
working with and also depending
on the particular
style of mathematics
you're doing.
As a consequence, we've built
everything in ChromeVox in a
very customizable fashion,
which means that one can
contribute to the way
mathematics is spoken.
Say if you want to work on your
favorite mathematical
topic and you want ChromeVox to
be able to speak all things
correctly, then you can
contribute speaking rules for
the speech engine or for the
ChromeVox engine as well as
just mappings for separate
characters.
For instance, here I've put down
a couple of equations on
the screen.
One is just a division followed
by a multiplication,
a divided by b times c.
And on the right-hand side, if
you're familiar with natural
deduction calculations--
some with you might be from
your logic class--
then this is a natural
deduction.
And either way, you want it
pronounced differently.
On the one hand side, you want
it to be pronounced as divided
by, and the other side you
want it to be pronounced,
let's say, the second part of
the rules follows from the
first part of the rule.
And I've put down the simple
JavaScript functions that
allow a user or a contributor to
customize our speech rules
accordingly for the different
expressions that you have.
In addition to just customizing
them by entering
effectively different orders
in which things are being
spoken and entering different
types of strings that are
being spoken.
You can also make optional
changes to, say, things like
pitch, rate, volume, as well as
pausing for effect, as we
had earlier in the quadratic
rule formula.
Right.
This is one way of
customizing it.
And then how can this actually
be used by people that want to
develop, say, an Epub3
reader with it?
Well, we have a fairly easy
way to interface to the
mathematics as to everything
in ChromeVox.
And if you just pass a math node
that you come across in
the DOM at the right level to
ChromeVox, either as MathML or
as the rendered MathJax in the
DOM, then we have a fairly
simple API function with which
the note gets spoken.
And you can leverage all the
machinery that we put into
ChromeVox in order to speak
mathematics with your own app.
And the particular API function
here is just syncing
to the particular math node.
And there are some other API
functions, which I'll now ask
Charles to explain to
you in more detail.
Thank you.
CHARLES L. CHEN:
Thanks, Volker.
So we've talked about how
ChromeVox works as well as
some of the cool new math
features that are coming out.
Let's see how you can use
ChromeVox in your own web
application.
Let me just refresh
this page here.
OK.
So why would you want to
use ChromeVox APIs?
Well, these APIs give
you, as the
developer, a lot of control.
It helps you to help give
ChromeVox hints about how it
should be speaking content.
It lets you give ChromeVox hints
about where the user is
in your application.
And the most recent feature that
we added with our last
release of ChromeVox has been
the ability to get at what the
user is trying to do on
your web application.
So for example, on ChromeVox, as
David was showing earlier,
when you navigate, you can
navigate structurally.
So you can say, jump to the next
list item, or go to the
next link, so on and so forth.
But what if you, as a web
developer, had a web
application where it had
semantic structure to it but
that wasn't necessarily
exposed to the user?
If the user wants to go to the
next heading, your web app may
be much better equipped to
do that than ChromeVox.
And so, in ChromeVox, wherever
the user tries to do an
action, we actually send it to
the underlying web app so that
the web app gets first
dibs on handling it.
And so if it can handle it
better, it can do it instead
of ChromeVox and just pass
the result back.
There's full documentation
available on this link, and
these slides will be made
available after I/O. But let's
go through some code samples of
how you can apply this in
your applications.
So one thing that could be
really useful to you as a web
developer is to be able to
speak custom messages.
So let's see how this
would sound.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Enabling
spoken feedback.
CHARLES L. CHEN: OK.
So sometimes you may be doing
something in your web
application where visually it's
obvious what's happened.
But it would be useful to give
someone who's using a screen
reader, such a ChromeVox, an
idea of what you actually did.
So right now, the code there
is how I am going to make
ChromeVox speak this
next message.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Code
highlighting off.
Code highlighting enabled.
CHARLES L. CHEN: OK.
And when I turn it off--
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Code
highlighting off.
CHARLES L. CHEN: OK.
So as you can see, visually it
was obvious, because the code
that I had bolded was
immediately highlighted.
Everything else faded out.
But it's nice to be able to
auditorial convey that
information.
And so all it took was this
one line of code here.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Code
highlighting enabled.
CHARLES L. CHEN: You just call
ChromeVox Api.speak, give it
this string of text, and
it just speaks it.
Pretty simple.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Speaking
custom messages.
Heading 3.
Sticky mode disabled.
CHARLES L. CHEN: OK.
CHROMEVOX VOICE:
ChromeVox APIs.
Speaking custom messages.
Function speak current slide.
CHARLES L. CHEN: Now what
you notice there is
I flipped the slide.
And it actually started reading
the slide to me.
So when it did that, this is
another example of using a
ChromeVox speech APIs
is that you can
make it speak something.
And I'm actually beginning to
lose my train of thought here.
I probably should have
practiced more.
But this is actually why
it's really cool to
have speaker notes.
So let's try that.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Show how easy
it was to add these AP is to
the I/O slide template.
CHARLES L. CHEN: Oh, yeah.
OK.
That's what I'm supposed
to be talking about.
So as you can see here, when I
press the key command to bring
up the speaker notes,
it actually spoke
those notes to me.
And now if I dismiss them--
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Notes hidden.
CHARLES L. CHEN: --it tells
me notes hidden, and it
synchronizes me back to
the top of my slides.
On the other hand, if I try this
on a slide where I don't
have speaker notes--
CHROMEVOX VOICE:
ChromeVox APIs.
No notes available.
CHARLES L. CHEN: --it tells
me no notes available.
So I was actually pretty lucky
there that I forgot my content
on the side that has
speaker notes.
CHROMEVOX VOICE:
ChromeVox APIs.
Speaking custom messages.
Func code highlighting
enabled.
CHARLES L. CHEN: OK.
And as you to see, again, it's
really simple to do this.
Again, it's just a simple
ChromeVox API speak.
By the way, you'll notice that,
in this case, I have a
couple more arguments
in there.
And these arguments allow
me to control the voice.
So if you listen carefully--
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Show how easy
it was to add these APIs to
the I/O slide template.
CHARLES L. CHEN: Notice
how that voice
was at a lower pitch.
So that's a way to give the user
a little bit more flavor.
In this case, it's to indicate
that this in a slide.
It's speaker note and
not main content.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Notes hidden.
ChromeVox APIs.
CHARLES L. CHEN: Now another
thing that's useful is if
you're navigating for your
application and a user wants
to suddenly investigate more
or try navigating from a
certain point, it's useful
to synchronize the user's
position with where
they actually are.
And ChromeVox makes this
really simple.
All you have to do is just call
API sync to node, and
you'll basically tell ChromeVox
that, hey, the user
is over here right now.
And it will position them
at the correct spot.
As I showed earlier in the notes
slide, this is actually
what allowed me to put myself
back on the heading after the
user dismissed the
speaker notes.
So it's great for focused
management.
And again--
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Code
highlighting enabled.
CHARLES L. CHEN: --really
simple there.
The second parameter just
controls whether or not to
automatically speak
or if you want to
speak a custom message.
CHROMEVOX VOICE:
ChromeVox APIs.
Handling user navigation.
Functions--
CHARLES L. CHEN: Now as I
mentioned earlier, sometimes
your web application can do
a much better job with
navigation than ChromeVox,
because it knows its own
semantic structure.
In the case of the slides, when
I'm not on a slide, all
the other content is actually
hidden, so it's
invisible to ChromeVox.
So if I were to search for a
next heading without any help
from the web app, I would
actually fail.
Because there's only
one heading here.
But since I give the web app the
ability to respond first,
you as the web developer
can actually say, wait.
I know how to deal with this
next heading thing.
I'm just going to do it.
It's pretty simple.
All you have to do is listen
for these ChromeVox events.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Code
highlighting enabled.
CHARLES L. CHEN: So you're
just looking
for a cvox user event.
And then it has a detail
object underneath it.
And if you look at its command,
it tells you exactly
what the ChromeVox user is
trying to do, and you can
respond to that.
And so I'm actually going to
use that to navigate to my
next slide by going to
the next heading.
Next heading.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Handling
user navigation.
Heading--
CHARLES L. CHEN: OK.
So as you saw there, it jumped
me through that slide and took
me to the next slide.
In conclusion, what we covered
in this talk was how you can
navigate through the DOM with
different granularities and
how we're using the concept of
granularities to support
special content, such
as mathematics.
And we gave you an overview
of how to do this with the
ChromeVox APIs.
One thing to note is this
all works on Chrome.
And as I mentioned before, this
works on web technology.
So this works on Chrome
in any form.
This is also available
on Android.
And it's actually a huge boost
for developers, because now
you can develop on the desktop,
test it out, and then
when you run it on Android
you'll get the same effect.
And these APIs are also
available everywhere.
In the audience, I actually
see someone
from IDEAL Group there.
You can go ahead and wave.
So they're in our Sandbox,
and they're demoing their
integration of their Epub reader
with ChromeVox Android.
And they're taking advantage
of ChromeVox's ability to
speak math to make their Epub
reader even better.
We didn't cover in this talk
is that we actually have
Braille support on Android.
And we're also working
on it for Chrome.
There's a lot more complex and
advanced navigation features,
such as working with tables
sufficiently.
And then we also have HTML UI
controls, such as date/time
and media widgets.
CHROMEVOX VOICE: Less
than thank you.
CHARLES L. CHEN: The best way
to catch all that extra
content is to visit
our Sandbox.
And so please drop by
our Sandbox and come
to our office hours.
You can find all of this
information on chromevox.com.
And all of this code
is open source.
And these slides will be
available after I/O.
So with that, I see that
we have about a
minute left for questions.
So any questions?
Please come to the mic.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: I have one maybe
silly question.
But is it possible to
set up a phonetic
dictionary that you could--
As we were watching this, the
I/O or the "AP's" instead of
API, could I just contextually
say, for this period, I want
you to, when you meet the
word API, use the
sound API and not AP?
CHARLES L. CHEN: Yes.
So that is something that we
definitely want to make it
easier and have it
work better.
In general, that's usually an
issue with the text-to-speech
engine, so you probably don't
want to overcorrect for it.
That having been said, we do
have the notion of being able
to tag HTML elements and
nodes with hints.
It's in the API documentation.
But you can basically tell
ChromeVox exactly how a node
should be spoken.
And this allows you to pull
in additional semantic
information and speak it
more intelligibly.
AUDIENCE: Would you be able
to modify a dictionary.
The problem I've run into in
this situation is you end up
annotate every single instance,
when it would be
nice to just be able to have
a dictionary of sounds,
especially if you're doing
science content.
CHARLES L. CHEN: Yes.
So that's why we have the
reading rules from Volker.
Volker, do you want to
speak more to that?
VOLKER SORGE: OK.
Well, for the reading
rules, you can
effectively annotate things.
You can effectively annotate
single characters the way you
want them to be spoken.
Particularly for certain
mathematical
symbols, that's important.
Obviously, in many ways,
it is like a dictionary
that you can modify.
It would be ideal if then some
of these things that you
modify on our end also would be
spoken by the TDS engine,
which is obviously also a
particular problem with
English TDS, which is not
necessarily phonetic.
Yeah.
But you can do it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
CHARLES L. CHEN: And ma'am,
you had a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES L. CHEN: Similar.
OK.
I think we're actually
running out of time.
So anyone else?
OK.
Well, thank you.
I hope you all enjoyed
this talk.
Please catch us in a Sandbox.